welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in in the featured bout of tuesday
night's episode of dana white's
contender series wrestling superstar bo
nichols submitted zachary borrego in the
first round to secure his second
professional mma win despite being the
star of the night and living up to
expectations dana white decided not to
award nicole a contract and instead
deferred to offer him another fight on
the contender series to give him a
chance to gain some more experience
speaking to host laura sanko white said
he's amazing he's one of the hottest
prospects in the sport he's 2-0 so what
we'd like to do is offer him another
fight in the contender series if he wins
that one we'd like to invite him into
the ufc despite not being awarded a
contract nickel didn't let it take away
from his big night telling reporters at
the post fight press conference he's
just eager to keep fighting video
courtesy of mma junkie
it's all good i uh you know i'm just
excited i was i'm always grateful for
the opportunity to compete so you know
getting out there unscathed
another dub
and i'll get a fight again soon so all
good and i've said this a few times
already but the goal is not to be a ufc
fighter you know i'm here to be ufc
champ be the number one pound-for-pound
fighter in the world so
um i'm 2-0 i've had a total of a minute
and a half of mma professional mma
competition so let's get another one in
there i don't really care if it's on
contender series in the ufc whatever i
just want to fight
nickel used his all-american level
wrestling to secure a quick victory and
when asked whether he would continue
with his wrestling first approach the
dan hodge trophy winner double down
video courtesy of mma junkie
i think i think anybody that i fight
for the rest of my career you know it
doesn't matter if it's my next contender
fight or you know my first fight in the
ufc or when i'm fighting for a ufc title
they should expect to
get mauled in wrestling if i want to do
that to them you know and i'm just i'm
just building my reputation i can do
that to anybody on the planet if anybody
on the planet comes out against me and
um
i can take them down put them on the
ground beat the crap out of them and
choke them out if i want to and i think
that you know every single opponent i
come up against should know that and so
for me it's about building my reputation
every single fight i have you know i
i'm i'm strong i'm explosive i'm
powerful i have better technique than
people and i don't get tired michael
bisping the commentator for the
contender series came away from the
night impressed with nickel but offered
some words of caution as well listen
he's chasing the money and rightly so
bit of caution though just because you
can wrestle just because you're doing
that on the contender series doesn't
mean you can come in here and beat the
best fighters in the world i've trained
with many a great wrestler guys almost
as accomplished as him and against the
fence it's a different world of course
the man is going to have a sensational
career slow your roll a little bit buddy
but nevertheless congratulations that
was sensational lightweight title
challenger islam makachev went on espn's
dc and rc to give more background on how
his title fight against charles oliveira
came together according to islam
oliveira didn't want to fight him for
the title and thought he should win one
more fight to prove himself worthy and
oliveira was instead eyeing a fight with
mcgregor islam then went on to say how
the ufc forced oliveira's hand by
suggesting a title bout between makachev
and michael chandler for me this is
embarrassing when the ufc lightweight
champion asks for someone like nate diaz
or conor mcgregor conor mcgregor who won
five years ago nobody remembers when
these guys win some fights he tried to
go diaz or mcgregor but he forgot my
name and when they asked about me he
said he needs money or something like
this but when he fought dustin or justin
gaichi he didn't think about money he
said islam has to fight one more time or
something like this but the ufc told him
hey if you don't take this fight we're
going to give some chance to michael
chandler that's why he takes this fight
islam then took a shot at oliveira's
inability to speak english and propose
that may be the reason why he doesn't
get the money he thinks he deserves i
don't understand this guy he tried to
make money but this guy doesn't speak
english nobody understands this guy he
doesn't speak english english is
important if you want to make money you
have to speak some language everybody
understands nobody understands what he's
saying on episode 278 of weighing in
with josh thompson and big john mccarthy
the pair reacted to news that nick d is
his coach caesar gracie would like to
see the former strike force champion
take on conor mcgregor however gracie
noted nick diaz would see mcgregor as
nate's business to handle ah i don't
think he's stepping on nate's toes at
all because nate's already basically
talked about what he wants he's going to
have this last fight against tamayoff
and he's he's out he wants to go and do
other things he i
believe like josh has said for forever
i think he wants to have a boxing match
with jake paul i think that's kind of
sitting there in the wings for him i
think it's a big money maker for him and
if nick
could come back and get a fight against
connor and make good money then go for
it nick if that's what you want to do
just you know commit yourself to
training and uh
i would watch i would watch nick against
conor any time
no i would as well i would as well um i
just don't see that fight ever happening
i don't fruition uh that fight's not
gonna happen uh nate's not gonna be in
the ufc after this fight coming up i
think he's he feels slighted also too by
what they've been doing to him i think
he's gone and the jake paul fight i get
concerned because nick's got to be
careful i don't think jake paused me
around much longer
it's my person i think i think i think
when it became
i'm a real boxer not a novelty anymore
um in terms of nick diaz nick is not
stepping on nate's toes i want nick i
want i would like to see nick get 100
healthy apparently he had two bulging
discs in his in his neck uh for the
robbie lawler fight uh i don't know if
he had surgery
uh but if he did john i don't know if
he'd be making a return any time soon if
he did have neck surgery
but it's it's a it's an issue a problem
but i want the best for nick man i'm a
huge fan
not just a legend in the sport
but just a good guy he's super nice both
of them are both nick and nate are good
people speaking of conor mcgregor
welterweight champion camaro usman
shared what he believes to be some harsh
truths about the irishman during his
appearance on the im athlete podcast
he's not necessarily done but he's done
as a champion this is my perspective
because when i fight guys i study their
hearts when i watch fights i watch their
heart and for me he's done he's done
because i don't know whether the goal
was to get the money when asked whether
he would fight mcgregor kamaru expressed
it as an opportunity he couldn't pass up
he could call me out but that don't mean
he's going to fight me it's not
necessarily that they protect him
because he's bigger to where he can pick
where he can call his shots he's that
big conor can say i'm going to fight you
tomorrow and he's still going to sell 1
million buys absolutely i'd grab that
check one championship tweeted out a
compilation of some of their most
vicious knockouts
listen to the sound of the coldest
knockouts with no crowd and commentary
watch one on prime video one august 26th
only on prime video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up
[Music]
thank you
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
[Music]
you